I did want to kind of open the floor a
bit too synthetic comments or things
that people have run across and also
potentially declarations of support or
of love or because we're we've collected
this huge range of things that will need
to follow up on but those follow-ups
will look sort of one-to-one or they'll
be quite individual if there if there
are things that you want to make known
that you're interested in doing that
might benefit from a kind of larger
airing or a larger something that will
require more than just sort of 121
direct follow up with us and this might
be a good time to do that I also want to
provide a or hand it over to Ted to
provide a quick preview of tomorrow
especially the non-technical track which
we've been trying to flesh out a little
bit in the course of these conversations
I think a lot a lot of the technical
side will have to wait till tomorrow and
see who's around and who has what
interests but we've been at least
thinking through what kind what are they
main bas I for the non-technical
conversation but let me just open it up
then to does anybody have any if we left
anything notably hanging in the course
of the day that you want to flag or we
can pick some of this up tomorrow but it
will be very different context and less
amenable to group discussion question I
just gotta make a quick plug for the my
prodigy the syllabus project called
salsa is at Utah State University the
OSP has been very kind to provide a link
to collaborative efforts on site and so
I would encourage you to go and take a
look at it and contact me if you see
that there's synergy what we're trying
to do and it's been said before that
it's not reaching out with little people
the other day and they were one guy said
well there's you know there's no
elevator pitch on your front page a part
of that comes from the fact that we are
open source project and I know the
problems of my syllabi and my context
with my university and some others by
extension but I don't know what all the
no other problems are and they're very
wide varied so you know we don't pretend
to have all the answers right now we're
looking for what Caitlin was talking
about people that have problems that
they feel like you can confidently so I
just courage you if you have problems in
this area that that it was like salsa
consult that presents us with your
problems and
you work very small with me and another
guy so he's very careful with our
resources as well but that were we're
deeply interested in everything that has
to do with this documents thanks
the question to what degree are your
efforts those of you who are working at
the missile myspace can sit I are at
universities institutional research so
the administrative Department of
universities that are responsible for
student enrollment financially time to
completion of degree icons data set I
would say the answer to your question is
that they should be very very closely
connected and in my limited observation
they're not very clearly connected I'm
just to what you're saying George I mean
there's there's no there's no effort
here to kind of try to own this space at
all I mean what we're trying to do is
you know and you said this at the
beginning and the other people is when
we're building on the shoulders of
people who have done an enormous amount
of work in this area and the goal is now
to try to take it to the next level and
on that basis to construct a kind of
corpus and set of tools that can help to
catalyze and bring together kind of
communities of research and communities
of practice not to own it not to control
it or anything like that at all so it's
not about only you know I was talking
about trying to understand because it I
think it's a very complicated and wicked
problem and so and one they'd just be
examined over and over and over again
and one that is strangely everywhere
specific but also i mean there's it's
it's gentle in the sense that this is a
sector of kind of commercial activity
people don't like to pretend that it's
not but people are paying a lot of money
for education it is but at the same time
for i mean then i said at the beginning
you know I think of myself very much as
an advocate for students and for every
one of them it is an individual Thank
entity
an individual experiences their
biographical experience and to the
extent that they're bringing that
specificity to it we need to strike a
balance between the generality of trying
to build systems that are functional but
at the same time preserving local local
things can I just go through I want to
shut up because we got to get out of
here I just want to say this if you
deconstruct this really all you need to
remember it is SBS WYM the rest of it
you could probably my figure out the
casing if you break that up into three
different letters you could probably
actually even memorize it Christine
could you recirculate them you know
around so that link leads to this
document and I'm going to keep it small
basically this is a structure it's a
kind of schematic plan for the hackathon
in sprint tomorrow it began as a
hackathon and there was some concern
that that would be sound too techy and
scare people off and the goal at this
stage is to involve as many people and
all of your expertise and interested in
care and commitment to the subject to
these subjects so what we has done is
open up a document that any of you can
add to any of you can change and if you
can demolish you can do whatever you
want to it then provide some basic
framework for things that we could think
about tomorrow not that we have to that
we could but the idea is to put the
other kind of birds of a feather group
or special interest groups working
groups to spend the day setting some
concrete goals and achieving them and
under the areas of acquisition
priorities approaches etc ap is you
should also see UI and UX architecture
development documentation corpus
analysis diplomacy and discussion which
Kenny talked a lot about copyright
discussions entity extraction
organizational development and
sustainability schemas and structures UI
UX and hopelessly soft questions anyway
so if any of you would like to
contribute ideas to the top of this
document there's a kind of a dumping
round at the top where you can just put
stuff and then we can try to file it
away it's vital that you come tomorrow
please do it please please please do and
also please come on time it really helps
to make things happen we started done in
it'll be fun yes